the FDA is reportedly taking
unprecedented action to stop the teen
vaping epidemic under the direction of
the Trump administration it will likely
announce a ban on mint fruit and dessert
flavored East cigarette cartridges as
soon as tomorrow the ban reportedly will
not include the sale of menthol or
tobacco flavors our investigative
correspondent Anna Werner is here and a
good morning so how our anti activists
responding well tony insiders told CBS
News that President Trump has been
hesitant to ban flavored East cigarettes
based on advice that his supporters
would react negatively to it now anti
vaping activists accused the
administration of siding with the
e-cigarette companies and the vaping
industry this policy is one that was
dictated by the e-cigarette industry
Matt Meyers heads the campaign for
tobacco-free kids he says banning
flavors is good but leaving menthol and
tobacco vaping products on the market is
dangerous menthol cigarettes are used by
more than half of all kids as a starter
product his group says one-third of all
e cigarette users in the US are middle
and high school students and 97% of kids
use flavored pods let me take take it
off the flavors for a period of time
certain flavors
president Trump hinted at the ban this
week we're gonna protect our families
we're gonna protect our children and
we're gonna protect the industry a few
months ago we spoke to 18 year-old
chance Amerada whose doctor believes his
vaping may have contributed to a lung
injury I never thought that I'd be
addicted and I'm sure every other
teenager or young adult would say the
same exact thing the Centers for Disease
Control counts more than 2,500 cases of
people hospitalized with a cigarette or
vaping associated lung injury and 55
deaths the CDC says the chemical vitamin
E acetate found in some vaping products
is closely associated with the deaths
and illnesses some people could have
used our product in August Toni de copal
sat down with then Jul CEO Kevin Burns
who said the company never intended to
target kids to grow the business what do
you say to those families those parents
about their teens using this product as
I've said this before I'm sorry that
their kids are using the product we
never intended for our product to be
used by them some vape shop owners worry
a ban will hurt their businesses arizona
vape shop co-owner scouts doug says
she's already expanding to hemp products
to offset a drop in sales if we just
enforce the laws we already have or
maybe beef them up have some marketing
restrictions there are solutions out
there to combat youth usage that don't
involve banning adult products Myers
disagrees this is not an issue about
jobs this is the issue about the health
of our nation's children we reached out
to the american vaping Association for
comment on this story but did not hear
back by news time Jul the market leader
declined to comment in the past Joule
has said that none of its products
contain vitamin E acetate alright Anna
thank you very much
you